tonight on Kitchen Nightmares Gordon
Journeys to Pomona California and finds
a fine dining restaurant that is
anything but fine dining I think we've
hit rock bottom the chef is fresh from
the hood diamonds on my fish good
diamonds on my fish I'm hot and doesn't
take criticism from anybody you should
know that [__] already not even Gordon I
didn't hear not one person complain
about him tonight did you what the owner
has run out of money I'm just surviving
the restaurant has run out of food we
don't have the s today no see bass we
don't have the KE the head waitress and
the chef are at War you piss me off
because you don't [__] run this [__]
don't blame that [__] on us and the prep
cook has sticky fingers did you ask
anyone for it no so many problems I need
the ticket I don't see the ticket so few
days service please this could be
Gordon's biggest challenge yet I'm about
to walk right now tonight bring it on
Kitchen Nightmares you are not an
executive chef let's get that
right
[Music]
Pomona California a small middleclass
town populated by aspiring artists
college students and car enthusiasts
it's home to Leela's restaurant a fine
dining restaurant only 8 months old yet
it's days away from closing its doors
hello I'm the owner of a fine dining
[Music]
restaurant Leela shouldn't be in the
Downtown Pomona Center there's a lot of
homeless people I don't believe that
Lela fits Pomona our restaurant here is
crazy I mean Ricky is he's always loud
okay all right let's go you know hey I'm
hot that's what it comes down to like
you walk into a club you know and you
just walk up D just be like since it's
my kitchen my menu you know I can do
that I have a knife Brian get away from
me we clown each other we have fun while
we're in here what the hell is in your
ear man this is 14 care go baby I mean
this this is a real deal Buzzard like to
stand in the kitchen and eat like to
Peck at the food all the time
buzz you know we're like one big happy
family hey I need my [__] order now
all we do is read the to put the food
out tabi man I just have to tell her
chill out now you're right back at her
ass I'm the one having to take this
guy's order and telling him oh we don't
have this and we don't have that don't
blame that [__] on us cuz it ain't our
fault Ricky I can't stand him me you
don't [__] know how to do [__] that's
why this restaurant run waiting the
problem with Tabitha is how she talks to
people [__] that orders the [__]
man shut up already everybody can hear
Ricky and Tabitha yelling when they yell
at each other [__] [__] no we don't got
[__]
Resturant I think they're overwhelmed in
here today it's really embarrassing cuz
your guests are like what is going on
back there like I just wanted a
salad like it was slow and then just
getting slower and slower and
slower I'm definitely losing money right
now I took all my retirement money
everything I had saved everything and
decided to open this restaurant I have
nothing left I think we've hit rock
bottom I mean we're like really going
down downhill I just wanted to see if
you have some money to lend me for the
rent oh gee I owe my sister 60,000 how
much 3700 I owe 64,000 for the line of
credit I'm stressing like how I'm going
to pay my bills and my rent and what I'm
going to do cuz I don't want to leave
her but I have bills I have to pay can't
sleep at night only because it's going
through my mind how can I fix it I don't
know what to do
so we're Downtown Pomona uh it's quiet
like a ghost town around
here this is supposed to be fine dining
but it's very very quiet and the place
looks absolutely
dedicted I want to hear his
accent oh look at this look at this look
at this look at this nice to see nice to
meet
you hello hi my name is and I'm your
server all I know about Chef is he likes
to yell a lot I don't take anybody
yelling at me um nobody and the sou day
is what please tomato basil tomato basil
fresh yes lovely thank you you're
welcome menu spelled incorrectly all
over the place are you ready to order
what is that there shivas what is one c
h i v a s shivas chives oh chives can't
even spell chive properly okay chives
let's go with a small bowl of the Tomato
Basel okay and I'd like to see the
nachos we actually don't have the shrimp
nachos today we have a chicken nacho so
no shrimps today no shrimps so no shrimp
cocktail
either okay um I like the sign of the
salmon uh we don't have the salmon today
you don't have the salmon either no no
what do you have tuna no I'm not sure no
okay we don't have anything and it's
really just it's irritating the [__] out
of me cuz I hate to tell customers that
we don't have any
I'll go for the speciality of the house
the roasted rack of lamb the rack of
lamb in a chocolate minc sauce please
thank you very much you're very welcome
very disappointed when you sit down and
start ordering and then half the food's
not available on a menu okay this is
your order bring it everything you
ordered we don't have he wanted the
shrimp nachos we don't have shrimp he
wanted the shrimp cocktail we don't have
shrimp for us to sit there and have to
tell customers oh we don't have this and
we don't have that it gets frustrating
for me because we should have everything
[Music]
everything wow here you go loveely I'm
not nervous at all what I need to be
nervous for you know he's a man just
like I
[Music]
am
interesting how is everything it tastes
like it's canned yeah so it says
homemade soup on the menu and it's
brought
in count the chef make tomato
soup probably I thought this was fine
dining so did I so I'll wait for the
next course
okay chicken nachs o thought that was
quick wow excellent who's that shouting
what what what what what our executive
chef Ricky look at them diamonds on that
diamonds on my fish good diamonds on my
fish diamonds on my fish diamonds on my
fish you have an executive chef in the
house yes and he buys in processed food
like what yes ah diamonds on my fish
diamonds on my fish we got diamonds on
the fish I'm good at my job I love my
recipes I let my work speak for
[Music]
itself fine daring naos something's not
quite right how is everything uh yeah
really weird are they fresh natural or
they bought in uh the Chef makes them
fresh in the morning yeah uh I don't
think they were made fresh this morning
my Dy Ricky when did you make the
tortilla chips oh
yesterday I'm about to walk home right
now the nachos like it was the cheapest
thing he's ever seen the [__] can you do
with nachos you know what I mean why
they call them nachos that's why it's an
appetizer you know oh
God the racka Lamb with the chocolate
mint sauce there's fresh mint chocolate
syrup I like it I got to be really
creative with with it damn that looks
good God it's so
quick okay where's the
lamp no no not that where's the lamp
uh look my ni's bigger than my
lamp what we're about to eat may the
Lord make us truly not
vomit it's going to be a long day could
you ask the chef is the Lamb Frozen yes
oh the lamb is Frozen yes he's just
taking bites of stuff is this Frozen and
I'm
like yeah is there any main course
that's on the fine dining menu That's
not frozen sad to say but now there
everything is Frozen Okay um do you know
what I'll skip any further frozen food
and maybe have a nice fresh dessert
please okay I'm hungry I'm starving I
haven't [__] eaten anything
yet yeah you know he shot everything
down pretty much you know but that's one
person's opinion you know and he's
entitled to it so that's that and what
would you recommend for the dessert here
you go for the dessert I would recommend
the brownie alamode brownie the brownie
Alam alode and you was like put your
hand up and swear to God that it's a
brownie that's made homemade from here
okay right let's go with the brownie
okay wow what a shame when you first
arrive and you're excited about coming
to eat somewhere and then half the men
you're missing 90% of it Frozen and uh
chocolate mint sauce with bones of lamb
there was a big ass pan in here full of
[__] brownies I go in there and
there's no more homemade brownies
Buzzard I don't know what happened to
the brownies I didn't do it don't ask
the Buzzard I don't know does anybody
know what happened to that big thing of
brownies that were in there
going when a couple days ago why they
were just in there like 3 days ago it
irritates The Living Daylights enemy we
should have everything that is on our
our menu at all times and we don't I'm
just I'm going to quit Ser [__] that
don't even talk like that man you going
to let one [__] just piss you
off like that no you piss me off because
you don't [__] run this [__] man we
should have all this [__] know what's on
the [__] [__] you talking about you
coming back here asking me what's in
this what's in that you should know that
[__] already I know the [__] all right
then no [__] ask me [__] we don't got
[__] now this [__] blame it on me you
shut the [__] up what's going on
coming up Buzzard confuses fine dining
did you ask anyone for it no for takeout
this is Buzzard's little picnic and when
Gordon steps into Ricky's space I just
tasted this it tastes like powdered
mashed potato they are Ricky goes on the
attack I didn't hear not one person
complain about him tonight did you what
that's coming up on Kitchen
Nightmares you coming back here asking
me what's in this what's in that you
should know that [__] already I the
[__] all right then don't [__] ask
me [__] no we don't got [__] now you
shut the [__] up what's going on she
always want to blame people for other
[__] she should know the menu don't come
back there asking be me you know what's
in the [__] kitchen you know what's
Frozen what's not what the [__] you got
to ask me for right um what was fine
dining about my lunch there what you
mean okay let's put it this way then I
thought it was a pile of
[__] I was embarrassed for
you okay you can't serve [__] Lamb
with chocolate sauce I mean are you mad
there's no meat on the lamb you going
blame me for no meat on the lamb that's
just what we buy here and that's what we
serve Ricky it's on the menu at $27
nobody else complained about it was no
one else in the restaurant was bitching
about the chocolate mint sauce on the
lamb people like that believe it or not
they come in here and order it all the
time so I'm not going to pull it from my
menu just because he don't like it what
was fresh on the menu as far as not
being frozen as far as not being frozen
not being bought in everything has to be
frozen we just can't let stuff go bad
you know have you got any bows got big
nuts much just cuz you come in here and
criticize my place you think I'm going
to give up n whose balls I think are
bigger his or mine put it like this well
we going to bump heads I'm standing in
front of a man that I feel that's got
his name on his jacket all the big
Showbiz embroidery and yet we're serving
frozen vegetables as a chef don't you
feel embarrassed about what you're
serving no I don't otherwise I wouldn't
serve it are you lazy I'm taking my [__]
off
nobody
[Music]
after yesterday's Fiasco at lunch day
two begins with Gordon inspecting
executive chef Ricky's
kitchen go a fridge that's not even cold
this is not a refrigeration unit this is
almost like an oven all this meat is is
virtually rotting dried warm congealed
blood at the bottom there the smell is
just just vile what is that God what the
smell
Jesus Christ I'm slowly but surely
discovering my lunch they bought in
tomato and basil soup that's finished
with chili flakes there's nothing
freshly made in this fridge [__]
now
Christ it [__]
stinks the lack of cleanliness
represents a lack of discipline and
Gordon knows he needs to send a strong
message to the staff we got to clean
Ricky I want the fridge walls scrubbed
the floor done yeah bucket behind you
yeah t take care of the dining room
Gordon had us clean the dining room
freaking sweep like three times mop do
all the windows everything with a
concern that fine dining might not be
right for this part of pona while the
staff cleans Gordon hits the streets to
check out the
neighborhood how are you I'm real good
good good good what's the vibe like here
it's young vibrant diverse what about
leelas the restaurant lelas have you
been there I have not been there what
kind of food you eat the pizza joint
right here what about fine dining
usually not too fancy kind of on a
budget no you keep the fancy stuff for
your arms right yeah and where would you
go out to eat there's like some pretty
good Mexican restaurants but like
besides that there isn't really anywhere
that's like in our price range with a
better sense of what will work in this
community Gordon heads back to Leela's
to check on the staff's assignment nice
nice nice nice nice looks fantastic ow
wow wow wow yes
clean while Gordon is now happy with the
cleanliness of the restaurant he is
still not comfortable with the relaxed
atmosphere that's not what your sister
told me last
night you did get
you this is kind of like home you know
just kind of hang out talk to everybody
on the
[Music]
phone I just Lounge
I just shoved a big old muing in my
mouth we have fun while we're in here I
mean what's the used to Happ a job that
you're not happy with we haven't met yet
have we uh no I'm Buzzard why
Buzzard eating everything that's right
like to stand in the kitchen and eat you
know you always catch him with something
in his hand I think you got a tape on
him the evening started out slowly but a
local theater has L out and a wave of
customers has now arrived at the
restaurant and follow me and I'll go
ahead and seat you
all right Ricky where's my salmon that's
supposed to be split don't be in such a
[__] hurry to do
[__] holy smoke it quickly becomes
obvious to Gordon that this restaurant
does not have a leader just two major
opponents Ricky in the kitchen and
Tabitha in the front of the house salmon
and a seab bass split SE
bass huh no se bass [__] man how come
you didn't tell me that when you seen
the ticket cuz I didn't see the
ticket I'm like really frustrated with
Ricky um us not having everything
sitting there for 152 minutes when their
food should be coming out any
minute I just found out that we have no
sea bass oh for God's sake is that what
we both ordered yeah Ricky doesn't have
many of the food items that are on the
menu and what they do have is
prepackaged and overpriced for the town
of Pomona I just tasted this it tastes
like powdered mashed potato they are
they taste all right you put a little
butter in them whatever put the sauce on
them they taste okay nobody's ever
complained about
them I didn't even know that he was
using instant potatoes I think Ricky's a
little
lazy holy mackerel is that a day yeah
yeah look at the day February 16th
what's the day today do not serve that
[__] cake end the [__] story
yes then in a dinner service that's not
exactly smooth sailing some of the staff
start abandoning ship carine I'm going
home we're still busy here why not the
Russ is over
wi are we finished or no I'm just taking
a break right where um where's buzzer
they gone he's walking down the alley
right now with his bag of goodies that's
the buzzer though you know it's always
he always waiting to grab something with
his damn
claw buzzard and one of the cooks have
walked off but they are not
[Music]
empty-handed oh a heart attack and what
have you got in there got a sandwich
from earlier um some pasta that somebody
ordered and one Jesus Lamb in there as
well yeah okay nothing about it did you
ask anyone for it no you need to go talk
to her and then let her know I have no
problem with I in the trash we'll go
together we wonder why there's things
missing after he's gone this is
Buzzard's little little picnic nice
little sandwich there ham cheese mustard
oh nice big salad and main course we're
going to tackle some New Zealand land no
you know where that came from stop
laughing here we are with the restaurant
that's financially [__] screwed and
you're just helping yourself to wine and
a four course dinner he takes little
things every now and then but I haven't
seen him do something like that in a
while
with this lady owns it
Buzzard
unbelievable Gordon caught Buzzard
taking food and wine from the restaurant
and Gordon is not not
happy arue with
you this lady owns it unbelievable we
were thinking that he was doing that but
I hadn't caught him in the act and today
well there it
[Music]
is Christ almighty
guys what are we doing
here just that Basics isn't even
together as a team I can't take
responsibility for for the whole
restaurant failing it's you know this is
the team effort here why did you become
a chef because I have a passion for food
that's why a passion for what food
you're making powdered mashed potato you
talk about the mashed potatoes I didn't
hear not one person complain about them
tonight did you what did you when Ricky
and Gordon were going at it I really
wanted to just like tell Ricky to shut
up where's your respect what do you mean
where's my respect for your
professionalism you are not an executive
chef let's get that right
don't look at me like that you back a
dog into a corner eventually you know
what I'm saying he's going to bite you
know I'd rather change my career then
make it out powdered
Mash anything you'd like to say before
we go home I just hope everybody's
attitude changes tomorrow so we can turn
this restaurant around if you still have
attitudes then um there's going to have
to be some
[Music]
changes
[Applause]
[Music]
it's day three and Gordon is about to
put his plan into action but one of last
night's problems has
returned Buzzard's here where is he in
the
back I hate to have to fire anybody but
then you get to the point where you know
if I can't get them to change what
they're doing or whatever then I have to
get rid of them
can I see your eyes can you take your
glasses
off um buzzer anything that's inside
this restaurant belongs to Leela yeah
yeah end the story nothing gets taken
off this
premises if it was up to me I'd fire
Buzzard's ass I get lots of people
stealing from me and I just have one
discipline anyone steals from me is out
end the story because the message you
send they will see you doing it they all
do it anyway Lea you're the ones going
to make the decision it's your question
yeah so you know I'm sorry but this is
going to be it all
right this is
[Music]
it buzard ain't going to be back here he
ain't going to be buzzing around here
and he's truly a buzzard let me get my
bag and my bang okay now that Buzzard
has been let go Gordon turns his
attention back to the chefs okay Ricky
let's go oh
boy okay little taste test yeah last
night for me the there wasn't enough
tasting going on there wasn't enough
identification so I'm going to pass you
a little bit of food and I want you to
taste it okay and then I'm going to ask
you what it is okay are you ready yes
yeah good I I didn't know what to expect
when he blindfolded us for the most part
I do taste my food okay good so one of
my favorite
Meats Ricky what was that it was
beef Lex tastes like chicken you're
right Ricky you're wrong that was
chicken what how you going to mistake
chicken for beef that just blew me out
of the
[Music]
water Ricky what was that I said it was
pork pork Lex what was that tastes like
New York
Beef yep Lex is New York strip Jesus we
already knew that Lex was going to get
more because Ricky doesn't taste his
food did you brush your teeth
morning holy
mackerel right blindfolds
off I expected you to get all of these
right and you didn't out of both of you
who is the better cook I'm the better
cook looking at him well we certainly
proved it on the taste test thank you I
am the better Chef definitely you know
without having to think about it Ricky
you happy with that no not necessarily
like Sand's a better Chef than to me I
know where my skills are at I know what
I can do I know what I do in here on a
daily basis you know I think we should
have a switch round yes Lena I'll just
found your new head
Chief don't expect you to just bark at
me and not expect me to say nothing back
cuz that that [__] ain't going to happen
I don't want to hear [__] from
you coming up at Leela's grand reopening
service gets Dera it's like a train wre
it's not only the front of the house
with f don't blame that [__] on us and
when one Chef can't stand the Heat
he gets out of the kitchen what the hell
am I doing here well if you can't handle
it then leave all right it's a dinner
service that will surprise you oh that's
coming up on Kitchen
Nightmares day four and to get ready for
tonight's relaunch Gordon moves to the
next phase of his plan but first a
surprise for the owner you my dear yeah
for the last eight months okay have been
taking care of everybody yes yeah you're
not doing that any longer I've arranged
for you to go off somewhere really
luxurious and to be taken care of you're
going off this afternoon for a bit of a
makeover pampering I'm looking forward
to the uh day off and not having to
worry about this place and kind of relax
a little bit hi welcome to sewa I'm
Sherry I'm Leela I hear you in need of a
pampering come on over while Leela gets
her makeover Gordon begins to change the
menu from fine dining to contemporary
casual starting with a sign your salad I
want you to think both of you yeah of a
Pomona salad Pomona yeah it's got a nice
ring to it just over the next hour put
together a Pomona salad I want you to
think of something exciting and I'm
telling you this is how C of salad
started if Bloody Caesar can do it
pomoma can do it use your imagination go
through the fridge look at the peppers
whether you grill them sood to them
sweet and sour barbecue SM them I don't
care give it some attitude well the
Pomona Sal he basically said you know
try to get the feel of Pomona here yeah
little me salt in there get away
absolute Tip Top get the black beans
onto there and the chicken onto there
this guy just opened up a $3 million
restaurant of course I'm going to try
and get all the pointers I can from him
like I'm back in school you know I felt
like I was right back in the classroom
you know scurrying around in the walk-in
looking for this looking in the reaching
oh what can I put in this you know what
I mean right wash your hands uh clear
the bench off legs please I want to see
what you've done both you yeah we have a
new Pomona salad a salad that is in
keeping with theeg area it's fresh it's
new it's
vibrant the Pomona salad is wonderful I
don't know how to describe the taste to
it but it just it tastes really really
good I walked them down the streets saw
Chinese food Mexican food a pizzera and
what no one has out there is a bloody
good burger and I'm going to show you
how to make a stunning delicious Burger
you know I could have made a burger but
a burger to me is basic chop beef salt
pepper Dijon mustard Worster sauce
ketchup finally chopped onions three egg
yolks to bind it together really
important to mix all that through yeah
yes really important tonight we're going
to do a special Leela's famous burger
yes will be the best burger in Pomona I
definitely feel like our less famous
burger is really going to help us
attract more people Grill it nicely this
is perfect this Grill have a little
taste seasoning wise that's fine let's
put the Burger on as a special tonight
Chef Gordon he was right when he said
that we needed a burger you can't get a
burger around here nowhere pona needs a
great burger and tonight is going to get
one the recipe to the lead Burger is top
secret I could tell you but then I have
to kill
you armed with Leela's new hamburgers a
catering truck and enthusiasm Gordon and
the staff hit the streets to promote the
restaurant can I interest you in a free
Burger sure sure I love a free burger
what about you think that the word will
get out on the street that we have a
really juicy burger you're welcome thank
you free Burger free burger right so how
was it nice we like another one I'm
going to get another one it's also going
to get on the street that Chef Gordon
made it surprising how happy everybody
is on the back of a really good
delicious simple Burger the grubbage is
excellent while the staff promotes the
new Burgers Gordon's design team makes
over the restaurant in anticipation of
tonight's relaunch we got a new plan a
new menu and a new interior Leela
supposed to be giv a new look yeah a new
unintimidating yeah warm place yes yes
speaking of new looks Leela where are
you my darling here we are
[Applause]
looking look at you hello good morning
good to see you my Dy when I see Lea
come around the corner it made me cry
cuz she looks so much happier how' you
feel my Dy good yeah let me say you look
great thank you yes you don't look like
a lady that's carrying the world on her
shoulders anymore when they saw me they
said oh my God you look so different I
said yes you have a new bus are you
ready to see the new Hot Spot in
Downtown Pomona yes okay we ready on the
count of three 1 2 3
go my God come in come in come in come
in come in come in when they opened up
the doors I was really shocked and
surprised it looks so much much nicer
you know it's warm yes it's inviting
it's no longer Stark and cold it's love
you got the reception here you got
chairs sit down what first caught my eye
was the the red couch the candles it's
like why didn't we think of that you
know it's in keeping with Downtown
Pomona oh my God look at our
station I think that Gordon did the
right thing for our restaurant just more
positive energy from all of us it's 1
hour before for the opening and Gordon
has mainstreamed the menu gone are the
fine dining efforts like chocolate lamb
chops and Soggy chicken nachos and in
their place are popular Fair like
Leela's Famous Burgers and the new
Pomona
salad all that's left to do is get the
Personnel in order we need a leader we
need a manager and we need to install
some form of
discipline Tabitha manage the place yeah
it means a lot to me that Gordon went
with the whole idea of me Bec manager
that just shows me that he knows that I
can do it Lex can I have you running the
kitchen tonight it's like it's the
biggest compliment I've had all my life
so far Ricky support it properly yes
well think it's fair I've been here
since day one busted my butt you know
what I mean let's get some identity and
work together as a team I'd rather have
somebody like Lex who's passionate about
what he does I really don't think that
Ricky's attitude will change this
restaurant needs to turn tables tonight
to stay open
[Music]
tomorrow it's relaunch night and Gordon
has invited local artists students and
car clubs to experience the new leelas
and now regardless of the rain the
restaurant is packed open the new leers
let's go all right good luck guys yes
yes you're going to need it let's
go good evening how are you just open
the doors right now man we got a house
full of people man when I looked outside
and I saw this long line I said oh my
God are they going to be able to handle
it it's awesome this is our new and
improved menu I'm pretty nervous about
tonight cuz I know that it's going to be
brand new Leela's this is our new menu
the Restaurant's menu has been totally
revamped by Gordon to better suit the
Casual neighborhood and tonight for the
first time the man in charge of the
kitchen is Sue Chef Lex Lex is the chef
tonight you got it yes it hurts I don't
[__] care you know I'm not going I'm
not going to cry about it I take
responsibility take it like a man pretty
much Lex yes I want you calling out the
orders tonight yes yeah don't forget got
it I'm feeling really anxious a little
nervous cuz I know it's it's a big night
for us two specials bacon and cheese
comes with bacon monterey jack and swiss
cheese there you go thats fantastic go
for okay let's go they're in with the
rain as well yeah they're not hanging
around they're just coming straight in
there yes here comes a mirror and to
further endear this restaurant to the
community Gordon has arranged for the of
Pomona to be here tonight I want you to
come in and sit down we have a special
table for you thank you what table's Ms
on 55 see where that lady is with the
red right are we ready to order Ricky
don't [__] off outside on the phone keep
it going yes me legs Ricky we you know
we we don't want to mess up what are you
eating now every time I look at you
you're always eating this is work now
yes I want everyone to get in work mode
yes and for yourself I'm going to try
the uh pot r I'm going to have the the
burger the evening has started off well
with customers responding favorably to
the new casual menu listen Lex first
table absolute critical but the real
hard work is about to hit the staff and
a little stage fright has set in where's
the tickets for the
chef Lex where's the ticket gone for the
Tomato bazer suit it's already been
taken [__]
hell about like 20 minutes I think
closer to 30 30 minutes into service and
leelas is off to a rocky start where's
the first ticket atex no food has left
the kitchen and this grand reopening is
off course hey guys we're falling behind
we've got to ramp up a little bit yeah
yeah what's going next is that the
Pomona salad there needs chicken where's
the
chicken oh come on guys listen BX work
together and send one table at a time
okay there's a lot of pressure working
in the kitchen so I thought we were
going to go screwed all up if this
doesn't work I don't know what's going
to work to be honest the worst thing
that could happen probably Le's run in
the Kitchen tonight it's starting to
become clear now I don't think any of
them are used to being busy so that's
why they're so far in the [__] and the
tuna sandwich and when food finally does
come out of the kitchen not everyone at
the table is getting their food at the
same
time so I'll just eat this and come on
Ricky not tonight come on don't panic
I'm just trying to say send it at the
same [__] time that's all yeah bacon
and chees first yeah the bacon is not
even [__] you know it's stone cold
it's not even crispy we got to we got at
least put it back on the grill for 30
seconds come on guys Qui [__]
meltdown we haven't had any food yet you
had any food whatsoever order four times
already seems to be taking a little too
long to get our salad I'm irritated I'm
very very irritated tonight everything
is not going the way that it was
supposed to go my chicken
sandwich god oh my god chicken sandwich
is going with the uh they just took they
just took the salad they just took the
salad what's going on it's not paying
attention to their tickets right here oh
the weight staff begins to panic get on
the computer and fix all that [__] so we
don't need the [__] key anymore how
about that grabbing whatever food is up
on the counter regardless of which table
it belongs to I don't know what was
going on in the kitchen I don't even
know where my order is like I'm I don't
care famous burger table
11 what did you order oh man they put
the wrong order and it's supposed to go
out with table 10 Caroline you put in
table 11 for this and they they're
saying it's not theirs it's a salmon and
a bake and a a cheeseburger it's like a
like a train wre did you have the
chicken soup no okay tonight was O
overwhelming sorry no he doesn't if I
said it's coming it's coming I need a
capan shrimp I I just told you I just
told you was coming right now don't ask
him cuz he don't know 1 hour into dinner
service and Lex's inexperience begins to
show they're taking different food from
different orders and that's not helping
us at all you stand there say nothing
I've been telling them who you told I
told Ricky already and we were trying to
talk to them get me T please yes right
there Le was trying to say that the
whole confusion was um because of the
front of the house Ricky want to try to
blame that everything's messed up right
now because of the front of the house
[__] don't blame that [__] on us cuz
it ain't our fault all we do is read the
ticket to put the food out trying to
stay on track with the orders and they
just keep yelling out they need table
you5 they need this table they need that
table you know people were trying to ask
me 50 million things at one time so it's
it's a lot of chaos it's it's a lot of
pressure I need
a you need it she needs it where's my
famous baking machine what the [__]
hurry up hurry up come on you got to be
fast buddy he freezes he doesn't know
what to do I I have to go back there and
actually help tell him okay look at this
is what we need to do can somebody
please answer
me all
right Lex what what's going on
frustrated and completely overwhelmed
what the hell am I doing here Lex leaves
the kitchen to go cool off outside Lex
come back here Lex is panicking on us
meanwhile Leela is in the middle of the
dining room Fielding complaints you're
waiting for grilled salmon okay let me
go see what happened there where's black
they're waiting out there for two
Salmons everybody else got their food I
guess there was two up here that he put
up here I don't know what happened to
him the point is they're not there all
right and I need the two salmon where's
black knowing how critical tonight's
dinner service is Leela finally becomes
a boss get in there there's two Salmons
people waiting for the Salmons why are
you here don't talk to me like that
you'll be out of here all right there
was something going on with Lex and um
the boss Leela some words were exchanged
because he wanted a break and she yelled
at him I don't appreciate that kind of
talk I don't appreciate you talking me
well I don't you answered me that way
okay I asked you there two people
waiting what do you want there's people
out there you guys are out here I can't
get a break for 5 minutes I've been work
work for the past 4 hours straight
everybody has you're not the only one
yeah but you haven't been cooking that's
the same thing you're not any harder
than ours is you're not working in the
heat like I am well if you can't handle
it then leave she totally snapped and I
I thought she was kidding no she was she
was serious you know I'm tired of these
people not doing what they're supposed
to do they just get up and walk out
whenever they feel like it and I'm not
going to deal with that anymore
leg what's going on she's just really
getting on my nerves like I'm trying to
take a 5-minute break at you know that's
when I got upset like what the hell I've
been working all night we're not
quitting are you what the hell am I
doing here no okay I can understand I
can feel the frustration yeah tonight
was a tough night hey Lex get your ass
back here
yes he's really upset right now cool him
down yeah I'm try I'm trying to I'm
trying to my
[Music]
God
damn
[Music]
[Applause]
damn with Lex out of the kitchen all the
pressure is on Ricky to get Leela's back
under control where's my cream at
where's my cream where's my cream Ricky
yes yeah keep it going yes yes if this
slows down now we're all screwed yes yes
gotcha I can still do it when it's time
you know it's crunch time you know just
kick it out table 55 is for the mayor
how long for that table V VIP give 5
minutes on that one 5 minutes please oh
hell what is all this [__] can I get the
ticket when you drop my order please you
sure can many people are still waiting
for food including the mayor of Pomona
and the pressure in the kitchen is at
its peak Le Burger where's it at is that
for table one is that the ticket for
table one [__] busy right now so
we're just you know pretty much all
going to have to step our game up you
got bed in the pot right there give me
the pot Rose let's move it let's move
let's move it give me two chicken soups
and get this ticket up out of here bam
with Ricky back in control food is
flying out of the kitchen success how'd
you like your pot roast it was worth the
way okay thank you some people complain
they're like when are we going to get
our food and then when they got their
food we're like oh we don't mind the
weight you know what if I wouldn't
embarrass myself I'd lick that plate
right that's the me table finished yes
yes Hallelujah come on that
salad this the best burger I've ever had
customers are thrilled with the food
delicious and the mayor is proud to have
this Restaurant in Pomona that Pomona
salad I think we will declare that
officially the meal for any Pomona day
$700 you have to pay the [__]
electricity bill and $11,000 to [__]
break even you got to go yeah keep going
got to go got to go you got to go how's
everything perfect great the menu is
great I mean people they really like the
food after taking a little time to cool
off Lex returns to Leela's not as head
chef but as Ricky's number two burger
right here hey dude s come on Rick we
can do this Rick right here it's me and
you Rick Lex took off and then he came
back just cover your ass you know it and
we did make a great turn around I got
chicken ready all right cool I got these
two right here okay T give me a Pomona
salad and give me a pop roast I was
proud to see Ricky really stepping foot
and taking care of you know situation he
definitely acted as the head chef thank
you very much see Ni to see it looks
like it's a whole new beginning really
for the
restaurant Ricky 2 seconds after a
dramatic comeback Gordon was truly
impressed with Ricky we got off to a
rocky start yeah and within 24 hours of
being in this restaurant I thought you
were going to [__] Bowl seriously I
thought you were going to throw in the
towel I just wanted to say you did well
tonight huh thank you sure we buted
heads at first you know but that was
just you know ego Pride pretty much you
know what I'm saying arrogance on my
part I just want to say tonight you
proved me wrong and I thought you did a
[__] good job and in amongst all the
commotion in the dying room you really
held it together you were solid you were
straight and you didn't blow it and I
just wanted to say [__] well done cuz
it meant a lot feels good to be back
though feels good to be back it does for
him to pull me aside look at me manto
man and say you know you did a great job
you know that made me feel really good
but now that you've opened the door
don't [__] close it keep it cool you
know what the score is now yeah right
don't
stop yeah
yes during the rest of Gordon stay Ricky
continues to improve all right okay cool
thank you Tabitha settled into her new
role as manager you feel yourself losing
your mind take a deep rest and breathe
Leela continues to be more of a boss and
more assertive with her staff I want
that calari now customers raved about
the
food very good and Leela's finally for
the first time in 8 months made some
money never seen that before but I'm
excited I'm excited come back again oh
yeah yes we will okay all right have a
good night thank
you right let's confirm one thing shall
we you won your first
battle Chef Gordon is amazing dude you
fought to keep your jobs it proved a
point thank God he came and he helped us
you know he turned it around the new
look of the restaurant the new menu
everything's like way better it was a
buzz a nice loud
buzz the changes that he made made here
they're great okay good night I'm glad
that he was here he had a hand you know
helping change the restaurant around you
know I thank him for that from this day
forward I'm going to remember everything
he
said in spite of business picking up at
the restaurant Leela's debts were too
large to overcome and she was forced to
close her
doors tonight on Kitchen Nightmares
Gordon heads to The Hamptons for some
traditional Irish Fair spring rolls with
mustard but finds a family Pub that's
lost its way get out of here doesn't
feel like a pub at all the father's
struggling to keep it together we're in
trouble right now get out of here watch
your mouth get out of here but the suns
are pulling it apart you don't listen to
anything I want to say you almost want
to tell him to shut up one hides behind
the bar I do my job everybody's happy at
the bar everything's good the other is
drunk with power enough get out of here
get out of here and the food they
serve this is lethal has sent the locals
packing we have to work I mean really
dig deep to get these locals back on our
side chef is not the best cook in the
world he thinks he knows everything
whether he does or not if Brian wasn't
my son I'd have fired him you got an
issue I'm out of here with only one week
to turn it around you can move faster
yeah let's go will Gordon be able to
find this family's pot of gold every day
you have to give it your best shot or
has the Luck of the Irish run out I
don't see how this is going to work
we're screwed that's coming up on
Kitchen
Nightmares The Hamptons is a beautiful
getaway for the rich and famous in the
summer but in the winter it's a quaint
Village inhabited by a tight-knit
community among the many eateries here
is Finn mul's a family restaurant which
is unfortunately
[Music]
dying Gordon Ramsey is here to Breathe
new life into it I know it's winter but
God you'd think there'd be somebody
around here this place is desolate
there's hardly anybody
out a come on you got a lot
of there he goes I'm the owner of Finn
mol's Family Restaurant and Irish
[Music]
Pub I was a police officer I worked for
the Southampton Town Police Department I
was there over 20 years already this
should be moved over here a little bit
and I retired and I was retired for uh
12 hours eight of which I slept and then
we opened up Finn mol's Family
Restaurant we are a family I mean that's
what we're all about that's who we
wanted to cater to both of my sons work
here full-time and Jason he's uh the bar
manager everybody's happy at the bar
everything's good yeah my problems are
more my brother help I'm going to kick
you right in the teeth I swear to help
yeah get out of here what do you need me
to do I would definitely not recommend
working with family no it's a pain in
the ass you're an ass I swear to Christ
you are I'm very good at what I do I
don't know if my dad and my brother
could survive without me being the
kitchen go away now you go away he is an
arrogant little
bastard I developed the name Chef
shortcut for him because he just cuts
Corners he'll deep fry bacon and they
come out like Pig's Tails it's like
chewing a bacon ball it's it's absurd
I'm in charge of the food and I have my
name behind it I know what can work and
what won't work he could be pretty [__]
at times you're so full of crap there
are times where he's very disrespectful
all right look at me no I swear I won't
look at you to the point where I I can't
believe the things that he says what do
you need it for I can throw it at you
Brian Jason uh butt a lot it comes
pretty close to
blows L well tell him to stay the [__]
out of the kitchen Jason you know tries
to talk to him Brian's all his ears
closed down no no you don't know what
you're talking about whatever grow off
this isn't Nursery School I don't really
give a [__] about their feelings it
would be great to have somebody of Chef
Ramsey's caliber come in and show Brian
that he's not
right I don't need help
cooking before I would just leave the
kitchen and let him go on his way but
the business is it's
floundering there's no way of anybody
knowing that it was a restaurant you we
put signs in the windows and things of
that nature but uh still haven't gotten
a sign out front I mean we just don't
have any money buddy is in debt
somewhere in the hundreds of thousands
my father's invested everything he has
into this business his whole life as a
cop and and retirement and pension and
this and that it's gone I absolutely
worry about Buddy's
[Music]
health I worry a lot about
Health it's not my boat and I don't want
to go down with it I don't understand
why he thinks he can be the way he is if
it doesn't work he it scares me to think
how much not only does he lose how much
everybody loses we need this for our
families I'm worrying every night going
to bed are you going to be able to pay
this mortgage and try to just barely
scrape by and make it happen I Can't
Describe to you how stressful that
is I
can't
here I'm at FAL calls to help a family
that are in crisis and uh bloody H looks
like a funeral parlor from the outside
not a
restaurant God so
[Music]
Grim
hello Hi how are you buddy maso good to
see you my first impressions of Chef
ramsy were that he's an intense man I
didn't know if he was going to be some
kind of a bastard or an eagle man or
something like that this is my son Jason
Jason nice to see you nice to meet you
good hello this is Carol Carol nice to
see you my first impression of Gordon I
think he's adorable I would love to get
my hands on
Gordon this is my daughter-in-law
Melissa Melissa Jason's wife my son
Brian Chef how are you are you well the
first time I saw him when he came in I
was definitely a little skeptical I do
my own thing back here and I'm very
content with that so let's start with
Carol what's the
problem we have problems with staff
uh-huh we have problems with
Brian okay he's a a bit arrogant and a
lot arrogant because I I say what needs
to be said and you people don't want to
hear it too bad that's not true we're
here to make money yeah and if you're
not going to do your job get out I'm
sorry Brian but it's does it stems from
him because he won't listen to Buddy an
example like Valentine's Day I wanted
him to do a nice Valentine's Day menu he
didn't see the need for it cuz we're an
Irish Pub he didn't think anybody come
in for an Irish Pub for Valentine's Day
about it's half the years it's the night
before Valentine's Day saying we want to
do
a talking about two week talking about
week before no no no no no but it's too
late for me to but it's your
responsibility to have come up with it
week before cuz you are the head chef we
don't every
TI come oh boy right now I'm hungry I
want to taste the food and let's meet
after shall
we I was pretty nervous I wonder what
he's going to see I wonder if we're
going to get really blasted you know
there's our lunch menu thank you I'm
like I'm about to serve Chef Ramsey like
this is so cool the clams are they fresh
clams um honestly there it's
frozen
I'll start with the uh Finn's spring
roll please good choice thank you can I
go for the salmon as well please tell
for main call I'll have a shepherd's pie
please I think okay thank you Melissa
you're
[Music]
welcome I I want to see you and Ramsey
uh chug chug yeah yeah I'll smoke them
tuck them in the bed good night
Chef I'm a very confident person and I
been in the kitchen for a long time I'm
almost positive we'll get a good
review when you get a family business
right it goes on for generations and
here doesn't feel like a family run
business at all pubs are full of
atmosphere fun it's got Tweed neck
curtains like you're going to visit your
granny weird here you are spring rolls
with Coleman's mustard well
go
it's a very strange bizarre looking
spring
[Music]
rad are they popular on the menu um
people really like them no doubt half
the Customs are
drunk this is the tough half hour of my
life not a big hit you like it no
Brian's in the kitchen like wondering
I'm just like nope are you kidding me he
really thought that I was going to walk
back there and be like he loved it you
know he he wants you to come work for
him come
on try out one let me get you some clean
silver wear thank you go and what's the
stuff with please uh Melissa on top is a
bomic reduction he likes to use that a
lot he likes that doesn't he yes he does
he on everything he puts a little
drizzle on a
little thank you you're
welcome always the sign of a very
insecure Chef when he massat everything
in B Mo V go look at
this horrible doesn't taste of salmon at
all off through does my shepher pie have
any BAL of vinegar no good lovely I
don't even think he likes the
water he said um will my shepherd's pie
have any balsamic vinegar on it I said I
can assure you it will not do I do I
dare I don't like to come off conceited
or cocky I'm very good at what I do I
know the back of the house very well
theyve done everything that's out
there let's try that
one enjoy thank you you're
welcome it's just a big bow of
[Music]
Grease just very very
greasy
[Music]
go that's
disgusting it second door on the
left oh
no my God something made it made him
sick I don't know if he went in the
bathroom and threw up but he ran in he
ran into the
bathroom
oh my
God coming up Gordon digs up the dirt on
Brian disaster and lets him know what he
thinks of his food you need to seriously
take a grip of your business but Brian
doesn't want to hear it you must want to
tell him to shut up get out of here tell
me get out of here you of his ticket
then and Buddy wants to take down his
son you got an issue if Brian wasn't my
son I'd have fired and if things weren't
bad enough I worry about Buddy's
[Music]
Health that's coming up on Kitchen
Nightmares after suffering through the
best Finn M has to offer it's time for
Gordon to have a little chat with the
chef clearly we've got issues when a
chef can't make a [__] shepherd's pie
it worries me my shepher pie was taught
to me by you know somebody who learned
it from somebody who went to Ireland you
know it's an American Irish pie tasted
like cough
mixture and then the salmon what on
Earth was going on there the salmon dish
that I put out to him always had rave
reviews from everybody that's had it you
could be eat in tuna from a can it was
that
overcooked was that you at your best it
was me doing what I do is I cook for you
I imagine the way that I would have
cooked for somebody that would come in
tomorrow night that I don't know every
day you have to give it your best shot
he has no idea what he's talking about
so whatever he has to tell me I don't
really
[Music]
care for a restaurant to survive in the
Hamptons it not only needs the vacation
business in the summer but a loyal local
following all year round especially in
the winter I'm at the fire department
what better place actually find out what
is Vin M's really about
morning guys how are you hi sir how are
you good to see you are you well I'm
Rick Schultz I'm the chief here how are
you nice to see you very well D thank
you welcome to the neighborhood yeah
very happy to be here tell me about fmer
[Music]
calls uh a lot of fried food really
fried food a lot of maybe a little too
much on a fried food what I'd like you
to do um if you could come back and come
and have dinner there as my guess
um
these guys here have got their fingers
on the pulse in the community and you've
got to look after the locals what better
locals to keep on your side the fireman
piss them off you've pissed the whole
town
[Music]
off after inviting the firemen to dinner
Gordon decides to do a quick
investigation of the
kitchen this shelf when was the last
time somebody actually wiped it
down you eat that
can ask jokes this is
lethal what what what what is
that so God knows how old was the
shepherd's pie that I had
lunchtime please tell me people do not
eat
[Music]
that cooked chicken wings raw food
against CH food what on Earth what is
that uh
oh for God's sake kitchen nightmare this
is a kitchen
[Music]
[Applause]
disaster there is one clean thing in
[Music]
here disappointed by the state of the
kitchen Gordon is questioning the
family's commitment to their restaurant
okay I went through the fridges and I
was pretty disgusted Brian you need to
seriously pay a lot more respect to what
you're doing and the first thing we're
going to do this morning whether we like
it or not yeah all of us is we're going
to clean I was a little offended I
always consider myself to have a pretty
clean kitchen me you and you we're going
to clean the kitchen yeah everywhere yes
it pissed me off I don't dirty that
kitchen I don't cook in that kitchen so
I don't want to go into his kitchen and
clean it all out off soaked and we get
all these changed and in quite frankly I
thought we were pretty clean
clean it was it was frustrating and uh
definitely embarrassing but uh even
cheff Ramy had some gloves on he was
cleaning I think that was more
impressive than anything to see him
being as hands on as he was guys
underneath
there spotless what a
[Music]
difference the kitchen has been cleaned
just in time for
dinner if only there were some
customers when we're struggling like we
are now it'll drive you
crazy why don't more locals you know
come maybe they've come here and had a
bad experience and didn't want to come
back thankfully the local firemen have
decided to take Gordon up on his
invitation good to see you are good to
see you it's now crucial that Chef
briyan take advantage of this
opportunity to impress the local firemen
I'm going to try the hot corn beef
sandwich I'll have the salmon order in
what is that naice
naos
me when was the last time we got fresh
vegetables in the house last summer last
summer now I just cringe when I see them
that's all I developed the name Chef
shortcut for him because he just cuts
Corners what they Brian big clam
casserole did you buy the clams from
Frozen you can't get fresh
times yes I can I have a big problem
with Gordon hanging over me watching
every step when I'm doing something
leave me alone and let me do
it 45 minutes into dinner service and
the firemen are still waiting for their
food 75% of the time I go back into the
kitchen my brother's on a cell phone I
say how are you cooking I even looking
at what you're doing how could you
possibly be cooking and doing this when
you're sitting there chatting on your
cell phone when the firemen finally do
get served dry they're not impressed oh
thank you is there something wrong is
that hot enough uh Brian 2 seconds
please so guys this is Brian the chef
yes have any of you met no these guys
are your locals start up with your pie
please that was it it wasn't warm enough
The Flounder was frozen wasn't very
flaky
since it was an Irish place I went with
the hot corn beef sandwich C but it
seemed to be very dry he's a volunteer
fireman I do this for a living and for
somebody to critique me who doesn't even
really do it for a living you know you
want to tell them to shut
up thank you okay you could bet your
butt they won't be coming back so I was
just like I don't see how this is going
to work after feeling the heat of the
firemen Brian and Sue Chef Francis get
back to work under the watchful Li of
Gordon who can't believe what he
[Music]
[Applause]
sees Francis Francis Francis Francis me
his death as a [__] B Daris he took
it off the floor put it in the fryer and
then back in the
sauce yeah well the frer is going to uh
it's going to take anything that come
off the floor going to but it fell on
the floor yeah you put it back in the
fry right in the FR and that cleans it
it clean it sterilize it sterilize it
yeah
well [__] me sterilized
[Music]
it with that order dropped the wing on
the floor stuck B in the FR
again we're trying to keep everything
consistent but
some things get messed up every now and
then what the [__] were you
thinking oh my god I've never ever ever
seen anything quite extraordinary as
that he serves food off the floor then
serves the
customer oh my God
[Applause]
[Music]
no still to come if Brian wasn't my son
I'd have fired him get out of here a
Family Feud sends Brian over the edge
would you care take care of this ticket
then I'm out of here coming up on
Kitchen
Nightmares it's day three and knowing
full well that Finn M's is the lifeblood
of the Mao family Gordon is about to
find out how desperate the business
really
is if there was no significant
Improvement how long could you afford to
stay open for we're in we're in trouble
right now you know we're probably I
would say $5,000 a week or $4,000 a week
under what we need to
survive under yeah so 20 grand a month
yeah just recently took a little
personal loan from a friend and I pay
him back you know that kind of thing
just to get us through this Dreadful
period here you know I don't sleep well
owing people money you it's not it's not
what I do I haven't taken a check yet
you haven't paid yourself yet on the
business I get my checks in the C got a
stack of them have a love are the boys
get paid buddy yeah everybody else those
but these
are and you can't you can't cat them no
I've never lost anything I've always
been relatively
successful Buddy's basically put
everything into this place by this place
not doing as good as he dreamed is is
just breaking him um difficult having
two sons in the business they know the
situation you're in I think Jason
understands more Brian's out on an
island a little bit um if Brian wasn't
my son I'd have fired
him ready yeah if this doesn't work and
it does
close what will the boys do this is this
is my you know our entire family lives
their lives I can I I can feel it you
know my sons eat their dinner because of
fin Ms you know their houses are warm
because of Fin mols and to think that we
would close it would be
catastrophic
with a full understanding of the
financial picture Gordon turns his
attention to the food beginning with
teaching Brian how to make a proper
shepherd's pie right give me the uh
large tray uh that we put in the fridge
to set and we'll put the potatoes on
there put it in the oven four or 5
minutes to have them come to your place
and show you what you should be doing
the right way put some cheese on there
Grill it and then get them to taste it
okay yeah to be honest with you it made
me laugh a little dra off that fat
that's what I got upset with you on the
other day that uh mean add that into the
mint into the
bowl to think that we are fortunate
enough to be schooled by a man like Chef
Ramsey well you'd be a fool not to uh
not to jump on
this let's go in the dining room shall
we okay so I just want you to have a
little taste of fal's shepherd's pie yes
Rich ground beef m mhm M this is good
ours originally certainly had more much
more of a brown sauce to it and it was
fatty
mhm then Gordon brought out Brian's old
shepherd's pie to
compare this is a b before and after
that's horrible look at
that I thought our shepherd's pie was
halfway decent it wasn't it was terrible
our new shepherd's pie it's fantastic
this is very very good I come out
looking like the [__] the family was
uh tremendously pissed
off after being humiliated Brian goes to
the
bar hey cheers guys good to see you guys
thanks for coming
out and has impress that I got take it
easy today take it easy people see Brian
has taken advantage of me all his life
if he wasn't my son I'd have fir his ass
out of here I know your buddies are
outside but I don't expect you to be
running back and forth every time to go
talk to your serious like okay I'm
serious all right I'm not kidding I said
all right
enough you're lost get out of here let
me do my job stay back here and do your
job chill
out nobody wants to get yelled at that
they're not doing their job properly I'm
not going to stick around for it why are
you standing right there hey definitely
once again again felt like a little kid
getting yelled at I'm I'm [__]
standing right here I'm doing what I got
to do watch your mouth watch your mouth
get out of here would you care to take
care of this ticket then I didn't even
want to be here anymore uh I don't know
if I wanted to be in the kitchen anymore
never mind here [__] off
you I'm done working
here that was horrible he's stubborn as
a mule you know he's just absolutely
stubborn he just
[Music]
disappears Brian's departure has left
the restaurant without a chef and Buddy
is forced to run the kitchen spring
rolls spr rolls onion soup onion soup
thank you what's that there cob salad
good so you're away with that you you've
done that before hav't you I'm thinking
Jesus Christ look at me I don't know
what the hell I'm doing back here what
is this uh f isn't it AB I'm glad you
find that difficult to read There was
eight tickets on the board I didn't even
know what tickets were up buddy buddy
buddy no no Budd you have to take some
out my man it looks like a crck of [__]
I know start
again buddy you happy with that bacon
there like
that looks [__] looks like [__] come on
Big Boy standards that's better service
please are you going a Hamburg out of
it it top to the bun what sorry top to
the bun top to the bun we only said half
a vow there was no bun on that let's put
it on straight away we'll argue
after buddy veggies please and Sun
fries is that other shepher P for six
coming for them but for [__] sake
buddy can't even find a [__] doily
let alone cook a flounder sweating
dripping now smashing plates his own
plates Brian's a cranky
[Music]
[__] it's day four and Brian's loyalty
to his family brings him back to work
you get a renewed respect for what Brian
has to go through it's a tough job it's
tough and a mozzarella stick going I
gained a lot more respect for my brother
and all these times that I'm hard on him
and I get angry at him and and we fight
about stuff and I couldn't do what he
does with a new appreciation for Brian
Gordon decides to spend some one-on-one
time with
him I knew you were an angry Chef
frustrated pissed off with your dad I
didn't know what you had on your
shoulders before I walked in here
there's parts of me that feel for you in
a way that I I started to understand
what's on your shoulders when you get
pissed and frustrated who' you talk to
who who' you open up to I'm not good
right to my little one have you thought
about quitting and and setting up
elsewhere
constantly yeah I can't tell you how
important your role is enough I've
probably faded out a little bit in
stepping up my game and to where it used
to be so I I I might have lost some of
the passion which is which is sad to say
that because I didn't think that but now
it's kind of over my eyes a little bit
about that you got to handle it a
different way in a way that you become
the responsible one and [__]
Focus if you got the security of your
food and you make this place Rock I
promise you that's going to give you
stability to run this business for the
next 20 years okay thank you good man
Chef Ramsey definitely kicked me in the
ass and got me excited to do what I'm
doing while Gordon has been dealing with
the family's issues his design team has
been sprucing up the restaurant in
anticipation of the
relaunch oh my gosh you walked in and
you felt like you were in your home it
was it was so comfortable it's bigger
huh holy Moses oh look at the booths
gosh warmer yeah wow I'm in shock I'm
never to Lost for Words you know this is
overwhelming gorgeous for buddy this was
his big dream it was very cool seeing
that just a look on his face when we
walked in there wow I'm
happy we've been given a gift now it's
our job to make this work and we
certainly will it's beautiful holy Moses
this is so exciting oh your friend Ms us
to hang outside for a little bit
something you've always always wanted
never had welcome to fin M calls
yes lovely wow established 2006 Family
Restaurant isn't that beautiful that is
gorgeous yes that is a beautiful sign
right there you can see that from 100 m
right I didn't know he would go to that
extent and and really go that extra mile
for us can't miss this it's tough to put
into words how much that means to me and
and the rest of my family buddy happy
with the color holy Moses look at it it
was very emotional we were all getting
teary eyed and the four of us were just
in
awe at least when you drive by now you
know what it is amen I'm thankful as an
owner of a restaurant but I'm also
thankful as a
dad although Finn M's has a new sign and
a new look it's the the food that brings
in the customers so the first thing I
did was got rid of 2/3 of the menu
because a you know the majority it was
frozen B it wasn't fresh what's the
point in having on there whatever comes
out of here has my name on it and I
don't want to mess this up you've got to
move with the seasons get rid of the
dark heavy sauces and line up a little
bit Gordon's new menu of contemporary
pub food includes the gness pub burger
and Gordon's own family recipe for
shepherd's pie and then the Fan's
Chicken Chef Ramsey dumped the fry Foods
they're gone and to give the restaurant
a new energy and to take some pressure
off Brian in the kitchen Gordon has
introduced tableside service T we're
going to be roasting a chicken we roast
it in the kitchen we're going to cut it
table side don't be nervous about it I
can see it on your face already yep
don't it creates a buzz in the dining
room and it creates a bit of excitement
ready let's go okay you and I in the
kitchen let's
go listen we've been through a lot in
this last week it's been amazing you
know we've learned a lot we've seen a
lot lot of things that we've done wrong
we' taught a lot of things and how to do
things right we can come out of the
blocks today and people can leave here
saying oh my God what a place this is
this is huge this is this is a grand
opening smile make people feel have fun
let's kick this in the ass make this
happen that's all do it from top to
bottom anybody have any issues
communicate 5 minutes go compose go
compose hurry
up the news of Gordon Ramsay's new menu
has spread through the town and the
restaurant is fully booked for relaunch
all right come on in Gordon also
persuaded the fireman to give Finn mul's
another chance don't look so nervous
just smile even when it's going wrong
smile okay this table right here with a
high chair five in a high chair this is
their one big last chance of getting
this thing right welcome to Finn Ms my
name is melissen I'll be your waitress
tonight this is our big chance the whole
Community is coming here you want a big
one or regular I feel filled with
excitement I can't wait for this this is
what you live for tonight's going to be
great Brian can I please put a ticket in
I'm thinking all right well I got to
have this I got to have this and then I
didn't have time to think of what I got
to have anymore because the ticket
started coming would you like a boo
great come on in we opened up the flood
Gat what's all this food doing up here
where's this going oh man
[__]
it's a huge night at Finn mul's the
locals have come out and the place is
packed tonight is without question a
wonderful opportunity for the Mao family
but if it doesn't go well it could be a
goodbye party instead of a relaunch
tonight is the whole new menu we have a
lot of wonderful things on there SE look
really good on the I don't want to see
any slubby [__] bowls I want nice
clean bowls nice cooked food and just
Pride tonight all about [__] Pride
yeah definitely this is a big big big
night tonight when I first arrived at
fin calls the restant had torn the
family apart now we've got a new menu
new Decor a nice attitude and they've
got to run it as a business we have got
one big chance and they have got to get
it
right adding to the pressure on the
kitchen is the presence of the local
food critic this critic represents Dan's
paper it's a local paper so you know
word gets out on the street new menu you
Deco hey yeah we got it come on then we
got it Wy wake we got
it hour waiting for an hour this is not
a [__] around this food critic in here
you know that we'll be on it we're
reviewing the restaurant they want a
good review they should give us a t rice
puding You' lost your smile go on I know
rice pudding that one bat is gone was
that it uh yes and start smiling You've
Lost Your Smile Chef is telling me
you're losing your smile you're losing
your smile how the hell could I smile
right now there will be there 1 hour 45
minutes I need the table back yes
absolutely I'm like oh my gosh just
please don't yell at me right now cuz
I'll cry and then I'm going to have to
go over my table and toss a salad while
I'm crying I forgot my Caesar dressing
can you get me a thing of Cesar dressing
Gran do you have the Caesar dressing or
do we they should have it
okay keep an eye on the salad for me I'm
going to run and grab it myself it was
just it was
nerve-wracking I'm running around with
the chicken when it's head cut off where
is the Caesar dressing I could go to the
without the dressing where is the you
got I know I was a little nervous there
dressing right here my bad my bad while
the kitchen is overwhelmed the customers
are restless I would think within over
an hour we would have her food on the
table while people in the dining room
are waiting a long time for their food I
waited an hour the fire chief is yet to
be seated I think we ordered before them
they're a little overcrowded for the
fire Cod you know what I mean every
plate is important tonight every oyster
every rep play every customer yes be
really careful cuz this is extremely hot
it was uh it was frustrating for sure
and uh definitely embarrassing pretty
much a three- R circus broke
out can I have half a lemon rather than
salad on there please yeah just a half a
lemon cut in half uh give me one second
I'm sorry I'm getting pissed now yeah
let's go with Chef Ramsey screaming at
me don't get [__] pissy with me it
definitely once again felt like a little
kid getting
yelled I've seen you work faster than
this yes it's a new menu but you can
move faster yeah let's go two pot pies a
stew and a sheer pie come on buddy come
on come on come on come on come on yummy
that's good oyster there you go thank
you you're welcome
enjoy stay in control briia buddy that's
for your
chicken buddy is nervous about going
around and carving up those chickens
tonight almost The One That Got Away
come on come on come on come on come on
while Brian tries to keep the kitchen
under control Jason is busy putting out
fires in the dining room I apologize
he's working on a brand new menu with a
the pack dining room all at once but if
they can't handle the new menu then they
can't cook the food so who cares you had
the new grand opening if they can't cook
the food in food critic just started
giving little brother some [__] so hey
prove them wrong come on do you need the
review I would love a
review we're serious in the [__] now the
bar's completely blocked and Jason's all
over the place he's now getting [__]
from customers we've got to turn those
tables this is the critical point of
this restaurant they've got to turn this
wake up and speed up Chef honest opinion
should I tell people at the bar they
might not eat
tonight we're going we're going I've
seen you yeah I've seen you work fast
this you going to [__] ignite that
fire yeah we're okay come
on 60 plus people here that are pissed
off at the chief for getting them here
tonight and it ain't right it was tough
it was tough people were getting angry
I'm pissed I'm
leaving what Chef Ramsey saw was was a a
a dining room that was a
disaster it was a horror show an
absolute Horror
[Music]
Show come on bri you got to step up now
my man she asked honest opinion should I
tell people at the bar they might not
eat
tonight our restaurant was
overwhelmed with the dining room in
disarray and the kitchen in chaos Gordon
steps in come
here you've got to take control of your
kitchen now let's look at it this way we
have to work I mean really dig deep to
get these locals back on our side so
don't disintegrate and the quicker you
get to speed with what's going on here
this whole thing is going to start
jelling a lot quicker I got a little
disheartened at first how it was turning
out but Chef fry wanted me to to be able
to show that I could do it give it some
fire let's
go the family begins to get it together
and the food is once again leaving the
kitchen but they face another critical
test the food critic I highly recommend
the chicken or the shepherd's pie
tonight okay if I had to choose between
the potato and bacon or the maligaon
what would I get motani all right let's
get breakfast St every time had that
order in now perfect every customer is
your critic but this one is a food
critic
[Music]
yeah I'm I'm sorry about the delay the
shepherd's pie is excellent any problems
just throw a glass at someone no worries
why don't I take this I take that but I
have to take this too I can take that
too
[Music]
okay be very careful not to touch
that and I brought little side dishes
for everybody you're
[Music]
welcome wow they pull it off it looks
like it's really black and blue there
are like five restaurants in the whole
country
that I think it's actually worth the
week they seem very happy they have
smiles taable she F sheer pie
delicious
beautiful now this is where this Pub
starts to make money it's turning tables
for the second time the atmosphere is
electric no matter how much money you
got in Hampton's you can't buy an
atmosphere like this extraordinary we
can put these two soups out here we're
on it we're on it buddy yeah yesterday I
said I was doing this I told you I was
going to pack the pl yes yes sir 24
hours alello the word spread and every
[__] turned up with their dog yeah do
me a favor yes stay for a while stay for
a while the dinner service ends
successfully customers are leaving
satisfied and the family proved that
they can make it work
byebye at least for one
night hey
[Music]
14 years of working in decent places and
crappy places and to trying to get
everything I can to have somebody like
that show
you awesome it's you know it's what I
wanted to do for a long time and I just
faded away I you know just came in and
went through the motions and then for
him to come
in and it would tell me that I needed to
get back into it and he actually did he
you know made me feel like uh I wanted
to cook
again no no no no guys let me tell you
what I saw and this is the God's honest
truth I saw a family come together there
was a buzz everybody felt it you know
and we were a family again the first and
foremost important thing to think about
tomorrow do not stop supporting each
other cuz you got a great family and
when it works it's beautiful good night
chef
Gordon Ramsey refers to me as a chef it
blows my mind don't you stop Big Boy Yes
cie
[__] he's put us to the test it was
very rewarding to hear Chef tell us what
a good job we did smile you yes I yes
yes detective my ass are you sure huh we
appreciate what he did all the work that
he did didn't fall on deaf ears I saw a
family come together I was proud proud
really proud you're a great dad you got
a heart of gold and two Great sons
cheers Take Care thank
you you know sometimes doing these can
be a right pain in the ass I have to say
this one was a joy because this family
now are united and they deserve to be
[Music]
[Applause]
successful
two months later and Finn mol's is on
its way to establishing itself as a fun
happening Family Restaurant clams are
just delicious really good welcome to
Finn M's this is the greatest thing in
the world greatest thing is to happen
the shepherd's pie is the Talk of the
Town and the pride of the local
community Brian and Jason have become
quite the team both striving for
excellence and supporting each other you
got it yeah you sure be it I love my
brother to death uh no question as for
Buddy he finally cashed his first
paycheck and at last Irish eyes are
smiling I have two sons that are
phenomenal I have a great staff that's
what that's what it's about that's why
we're here this is what we plan for I
love
[Music]
it